[موسيقى]
لذلك مجتمعنا الروسي والمطبخ
اللبنانيين وخاصة الغجر و
كانوا أول من نفذوها في
باريس في عام 2002 - وتكاليف بيير برميل
اللعبة شأن عائلي
تجد شارع رامبوتو الحب الآن
قبل عام وشارع quincampoix
ثم ظهر تخصصنا
انها فجأة كعكة مانيش و
لذلك فجأة تهاجم قاعدة
جاليت التي ستكون حبة من
السمسم
جنيهين و سماق للتسليم
مباشرة على الجزء السفلي من الفرن
يتم تقريب الكيس التقليدي لـ
توزيع الحرارة
بمجرد طهيها يمكنك إضافة
بعد بعض المكونات بما في ذلك
أسرة مزروعة فليكن ذلك دو
يجب أن يكون نظام التشغيل الكروم قد أحضره أو نحو ذلك
الجبن مثل الجبن الخشخشة أو نحو ذلك
إنه طبق نأكله في وقت مبكر من اليوم
صباحًا ، لذا فهو في الواقع طبق شهي
طعم البشرة حاضر جدا أخيرًا
لبضع سنوات في فرنسا
اهتمام كبير بالطبخ
لبناني
ثم الجانب الصارم
حاول م
[موسيقى]